two weeks ago labor picked aside in the
brexit debate and announced that they
would officially back a second
referendum but since then it's fair to
say not much has actually been done to
bring a second referendum about so how
does labour plan to shape brexit in the
critical weeks ahead
well we're joined now by Labour's shadow
Bret's at secretary it's okay Starla
thank you very much for being in the
studio well we've got loads to get
through on brexit as always and but it
feels that we should start start on a
different story and shimmy bacon yes you
of course with former Director of Public
Prosecutions yourselves I'm interested
to know your views on whether or not the
child of Shamima babe and that three
week old who died in the Syrian refugee
camp if they've been failed somehow by
the government well I think the decision
was by the Home Secretary was the wrong
decision and I think it was a rushed
decision and I think it left out of
account the interests of the newly born
child who's tragically died I think Home
Secretary also should have really looked
at what powers were available to him to
deal with the case if it came back how
terrorism acts are very wide-ranging now
so if you commit an offense in another
country you could be prosecuted back
here in the United Kingdom and I've done
many of those cases alternatively if
there's not enough evidence if she came
back and there wasn't enough evidence to
prosecute you can also have a prevention
order which is where you can't prosecute
what you think measures are necessary so
a lot of people have escaped prosecution
haven't they you've gone to Syria and
come back has been difficult to
prosecute well they need to be assessed
when they come back security and
intelligence forces can do that and they
do do that and they're very good at it
if there are offences the mere fact that
it was abroad makes no difference you
can be prosecuted here but as I say if
on analysis it was found there wasn't
enough evidence the home story could
then have said well what about a
prevention order which limits what an
individual can do back in this country
so actually had the interest of the
child been taken properly into account I
think we would see that this was a wrong
decision and a rough decision by the
Home Secretary another former Director
of Public Prosecutions Lord McDonald yes
I have spoken to the observer this
morning have a look at something that he
said about that decision mr. Jabez
behavior is a recipe for refugee chaos
and moral cowardice of the worse sort is
he right well he's got a being tended
alone cases as I did under Terrorism Act
he knows exactly what could be done back
here I think what he says is it is right
I think actually the Home Secretary
needs to come to Parliament tomorrow
make a statement on this and face
questions I think that's the right thing
to do in the circumstances as they now
are because I think there is a growing
feeling that this decision wasn't
properly made and the tragic
consequences are now that a newborn
child has died okay let's move on to
your official favourite subject for
exits and now of course we was
mentioning in the introduction to the
interview that you are now officially
supporting the idea of a second brexit
vote so are you gonna be putting down an
amendment for a second referendum public
the position that Jeremy Corbyn outlined
the week before last is that we will
leave the table or support a an
amendment in favor of a public vote the
timing of that is really important this
Tuesday is obviously the opportunity we
get to vote again on the deal and I
think there's a growing feeling that
this Tuesday should be pretty well a
straight up down vote on on that deal
because what we've seen is that the deal
itself 585 patient withdrawal agreement
26 page of the political declaration 610
pages that was signed off on the 25th of
November last year by the EU 27 by the
UK it was then voted on eight weeks ago
on 15th of January as you know went down
by 230 votes not one word of that has
ever been changed and so what we're
going to get on Tuesday it seems unless
something dramatic happens is the
extraordinary thing where the Prime
Minister will bring exactly the same
deal exactly the same not a word
different and put it before Parliament
eight weeks after she left you to give
some more assurances they want but
they're hoping for that but they've been
for weeks and weeks and weeks going
backwards and forwards backs and for
saying we want changes to the backstop
they're getting absolutely nowhere and
one of one of the things I've tried to
raise in the House of Commons over no
forget is the Prime Minister is raising
expectations that she will not fulfill
now I don't know whether something
dramatic will happen in the next 24
hours
but unless it does exactly the same deal
exactly the sender is going to be put
before problem on both sides of the
house there's can be a growing
frustration about that because that is
eight weeks of failure to come back and
present exactly what was rejected and so
on Tuesday that has got to be exposed it
cannot go on like that and then
obviously on Wednesday and on Thursday
if the deal goes down we've got the
opportunity to deal with this issue of
no deal and then to go on and deal with
the pelvic stage because I can't help
but thinking that you're talking about
the growing frustration of MPs that
there'll be a growing frustration of
Labor Party members that there is no
amendment being tabled on a second
referendum I can just show you what John
McDonnell said ten days ago he said when
the meaningful vote comes back that's
the time when we will have to put the
amendment up so why aren't you putting
one off well we have to make decisions
about what is going to happen on Tuesday
there was an expectation that the deal
would be different I think across
Parliament now people know the deal is
the same there is a strong sense that it
should be an up down vote on with you
now that's not that's not just a sort of
labor position with it back in on the
15th of January when we first went
through this exercise there were lots of
amendments down a man in the end across
the house everybody pretty well pulled
their amendments and said we need to
know the size of the defeat if it is a
defeat and I think we're at back at that
moment on Tuesday doesn't mean that the
public votes gone it doesn't mean we
won't come to it but it means that we do
it I mean Tuesday is about exposing the
weakness of the prime minister and then
when are you going to do it and well
we'll have to work with others across as
you know as well as I do if there's to
be a winning amendment or anything it
normally comes from the back bencher on
the front bench and that's you might not
put an amendment down at all then well
we will be putting down amendments to be
amendments probably on Tuesday but as I
say that the feeling about Tuesday is
that that should expose the weakness of
the prime estate we then go on the next
day to deal with No Deal so if the prime
ministers deal goes down Parliament will
then vote on whether there should be no
deal if Parliament says there should be
we should say no to No Deal I'm sure it
will will
on Thursday to deal with should there be
an extension so and then the week after
that I have to be further votes or more
calendar section 13 procedure so there's
going to be plenty of opportunities for
amendments but but I do come back to the
central point about Tuesday because this
isn't just an opposition thing I think
if you look across the house the
frustration I think the disbelief that
the chemistry is literally going to put
the same deal back and eight weeks later
and so when you didn't vote for it last
time vote for it now yes I can't help
thinking that you know a cynic would
look at what's happening and say labor
is just dangling the prospect of a
second referendum to satisfy its
membership with no intention of actually
doing what's needed to make it happen
well Sophie we we've been absolutely
clear that we are supporting a public
vote and Locke if you like on the prime
ministers deal we have to work that you
have to work across the house everybody
has to assess when it's the right time
to put amendments and to vote on them
and in the end we have to work with our
back benches if every pretty well
everything we we've won or achieved in
the last two years there's been where a
bat bench has put down an amendment and
then sufficient MPs have got behind it
and that's what needs to happen now one
of the crucial votes that we're
expecting this week is on a potential
delay we know how Labour's going to vote
on Theresa May Steele would know how you
can devote on No Deal
so when it comes to a delay of brexit
how long is acceptable well the first
thing I need to say about this is this
is not a policy of choice nobody's been
championing an extension this this is
now necessary because of the position we
find ourselves it in my discussions in
Brussels it seems clear that a delay or
an extension of about three months is
probably doable beyond that it becomes
much more difficult so we need to look
at that sort of period in the first
instance but the most important thing I
think is what are we going to use this
period for what we cannot have we just
cannot have is a prime minister at the
end of this week say ah I now see it's
all about the backstop that's the
problem I'm going to carry on and I'll
have further discussions and
negotiations about the backstop with
that with our EU
partners we've got to stop that and say
right if there is to be an extension
what are we going to use that period for
I mean one of the ideas that is being
seriously discussed is this kind of
norway's style agreement jeremy corbyn
we know met with a group of MPs who are
putting that agreement would include
some conservatives and usually for the
Labour leader what happened in that
meeting and is this something that
Labour is seriously considering look
across the House of Commons there are
all sorts of proposals about finding a
way through breaking the impasse and the
so-called Norway model and come and
market to is one of those and I think
everybody is looking seriously at all
the propositions so you are looking
seriously I'm bucking it we have got to
break the impasse we've got a deal that
isn't getting through and we can't just
keep running down the clock so and this
is the point for the promise to sooner
or later Pearlman is going to have to
decide what happens next now we have
been saying there should be a close
economic relationship with a customs
union and single market alone alignment
we're also saying there should be a
public vote so it's clear where we are
but of course we've got to talk to
people across the house because we've
got to find a majority so that we can
actually move forward otherwise the
extension however long it is is not
going to be capable of actually
resolving this and as you know I think
across the country people are saying
you've got to break the impasse in in
the spirit of trying to provide clarity
we're talking there about Norway some of
the different deals that could happen if
the UK stays in we're also talking about
the idea of a second public vote where
presumably remain will be on the ballot
paper so just to be really really clear
about Labour's position do you want to
leave or not well we we campaigned to
remain but when the result came out we
said we accept the results and then we
see one today in but in the twenty seven
manifesto we said we would trigger
article 50 we would and we voted to
trigger article 50 in good faith the
beginning of the two-year period and
said to the prime is to go off and
negotiate at the very beginning we said
these are the conditions when you come
back we're not going to accept anything
you come back with these are the
conditions for accepting your deal we've
now got to the end of the exercise and
we are staring at the same deal with
same red lines which we reject or no
deal and it's in those circumstances
that the Labour Party has said against
that backdrop there ought to be a public
vote City we will stay in it well we
have at the moment we've taken a
decision to leave we've got to where we
are if there's a public vote that that
would operate as a lock if you like on
any deal that Theresa May gets through
if that is the position then in my view
the default ought to be remain if we are
in that situation as I said last time I
was across this table with you I would
personally vote remain but this has to
be seen in its context because the whole
process is a two-year process during
which the Prime Minister should have
negotiated a deal she hasn't got a deal
that's going to be acceptable to
Parliament and so we now have to assess
the position that we're actually in
invest that's why we're now backing a
public vote
okay now a little later on the show and
we have been looking at some of the
abuse that well and piece of both
genders but typically women have
suffered in their kind of week live
International Women's Day and we spoke
to 33 million piece of which more than
half said that they had suffered death
threats and now there was a very open
interview by Jess Phillips your
colleague in these times yesterday and I
just want to ask your opinion on one of
the things that she said in that
interview she said this and the left is
misogynist Marxism has always had a
problem with women because class is
everything do you think she's right well
that's a very broad statement from Jess
who's always worth listening to on these
issues it is certainly a fact that women
get far more abuse than men whether
that's online or directly and the
increase in death threats is really
worrying this has happened across
Parliament and particularly in recent
months and I know personally a number of
MPs
women MPs we've had death threats and
the impact it has on them is profound
and I think this descent into a
use and threats is something we
absolutely need to tackle in the same
interview and she also said that she'll
give labor one more roll of the dice but
it doesn't own me so I wondered do you
feel like that or you have more of the
Emily Thornberrys school that you'd
rather die than leave the Labour Party
well look I'm not leaving the Labour
Party I am staying in the Labour Party
because I'm determined that we will deal
with the problems that we've got at the
moment and do what we're here for which
is to have progressive change for the
future so I'm staying I want everybody
to stay and to pull together on this but
it's a low moment it is a low moment
when fellow MPs leave and members leave
and we need to confront that we need to
listen and reflect on why that has
happened so that's the challenge for a
party just at the moment